[Musique]
lui somme strong 10 sont ni merveille
mans dans cette chanson what a wonderful
world
est-ce que vous avez un jour peut-être
imaginer que cette chanson est au fait
un hymne ironique armstrong la voix
souriante
alors que l'amérique est en feu à cause
des émeutes raciales défis ceux qui
entretiennent la ségrégation le 15 avril
vous supplie t in the sky office of
people go in by ainsi french et keynes
c'est une attitude ou bud everything
alain view rainbow l'oeuf
oui l'amour et pour tous pas seulement
pour une catégorie
et pourtant j'aurais pu transposer cette
chanson pour évoquer la situation de
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas la liberté
de ces mets et vous devez vous demandez
peut-être vous avez le droit de vous le
demander ce qu une mamie de 64 en fait
sur la scène de tadic ce soir pour
parler du droit d'aimer ce combat
s'inscrit au même titre à tous les
combats que je mène déjà pour le respect
des droits humains contre la
discrimination et la stigmatisation
il y a une dizaine d'années une nouvelle
ong
le collectif arc-en-ciel créée pour
lutter contre l'homophobie et les
discriminations liées à l'orientation
sexuelle vient me voir pour me demander
d'être leur marraine
j'ai accepté tout de suite
même si à ce moment là - j'avais décidé
de changer un peu de cap
vous allez rigoler mais je voulais
devenir une femme fatale et on venait
chercher un mali figure
comme quoi chassez le naturel il revient
au galop
mais je suis très honoré d'être un des
porte drapeaux de ce collectif et de la
lutte en général contre la
discrimination liée à l'orientation
sexuelle pour la communauté lgbt à
maurice il a tellement raison le grand
nelson mandela quand il dit priver
quelqu'un de ses droits fondamentaux
équivaut à renier son humanité
le droit d'aimer passe automatiquement
fait je pense par cette reconnaissance
ce droit d'être soi en ce droit est
refusée à tous ceux qui ont une
orientation sexuelle différente
on se pose des questions beaucoup de
questions à ce sujet est-ce que c'est
par rapport à une société souvent la map
dont la majorité en tous cas pense que
c'est l'énorme est ce que c'est le bien
pensé le droit chemin
avons nous le droit de stigmatiser les
gens et faut-il être un standard pour
être acceptée nous nous élevons souvent
et avec raison certainement contre le
racisme contre les différentes
discriminations religieuses économiques
pour l'égalité pour tous pour la justice
sociale mais nous devenons soudain
frileux quand il s'agit de l'orientation
sexuelle ont fait 2 par comme ça en
arrière parce que ces choses là on n'en
parle pas beaucoup
est-ce que les lesbiennes les gays les
bisexuels et transgenres sont des sous
humains des sous-citoyens juste à cause
de leur choix de vie cette question a
été relevée récemment dans une
magnifique conférence à maurice donné
par le ministre indien de la justice
l'inde un pays qui a décriminalisé
l'homosexualité
souvent nous entendons des remarques est
soutenable dans les stades pour des
joueurs de foot à cause de la couleur de
peau et nous nous élevons nous sommes
choqués par ces remarques
nous sommes choqués quand un poste est
refusée à une femme ou quand on choisit
plutôt un homme qu'une femme à ce poste
parce que cette femme elle a des enfants
en bas âge elle pourrait avoir d'autres
grossesses et absentéisme éventuelle
mais sommes-nous choqué de la même
manière quand il s'agit de personnes un
peu efféminé jugé trop féminine pour un
job jugé trop masculine pour l'autre job
je repose la question avons nous le
droit de stigmatiser des personnes par
rapport à leur orientation sexuelle
je comprends que ces choses là et je le
conçois sont délicates on n'en parle pas
souvent ou bien si on en parle c'est
avec des idées bien arrêtées
mais pour ceux qui sont dans le cas il
se pose la question comment en parler
avec cette peur au ventre qui vous
tenaille
est ce que je serai vue de la même façon
si j'avoue quelque chose si je dis qui
je suis vraiment est ce que on va
m'aimer
de la même façon on va me voir de la
même façon
et on continue souvent à cause de cela
avec une vie d'hypocrisie de mensonges
de faire semblant et pour la famille le
choc
souvent dans le déni souvent avec un
profond sentiment de culpabilité ou elf
fauté et le résultat est souvent
dramatique
on l'a vu encore récemment chez nous à
maurice des vies brisées des vies ratées
je reprends des propos souvent entendu
et je partage ce de l'ex secrétaire des
nations unies ban ki moon qui dit il
faut pourtant apprendre à en parler
parce que des vies humaines sont en jeu
et parce que c'est notre devoir en vertu
de la déclaration universelle des droits
de l'homme de protéger les droits de
tous partout ça donne à réfléchir et on
pourrait penser qu'à maurice nous nous
en sortons plutôt pas mal par rapport à
la liberté d'expression
mais ça c'était avant avant l'année
dernière quand la gay pride
la marche des fiertés comme nous
l'appelons n'a pu avoir lieu comme tous
les ans à cause des agissements de
certaines personnes qui n'ont pas permis
à ceux des pride d'avoir lieu un coup
dur pour la communauté lgbt un coup de
vieux surtout pour la démocratie de
notre pays et cela me permet de vous
rappeler qu'il y à quelques obligations
légales décrétée par les nations unies
décriminaliser l'homophobie et les
personnes transgenres protéger les
personnes contre les traitements
inhumains dégradants protéger de la
violence transphobes et homophobes et
bien sûr protégé aussi la liberté
d'expression les minorités vous savez on
peut les négligés mais ils ont leur mot
à dire
ils ont leur mot à dire parce que la
liberté d'être soi passe par la liberté
d'aimer qui l'on veut sans peur sans
honte parce que l'orientation sexuelle
c'est une affaire aussi de liberté
individuelle qui ne concerne ni vous ni
moi ni personne parce que l'égalité
passe aussi par le respect de la dignité
et de la diversité des femmes et des
hommes qui ont choisi d'être différent
et je vous pose la question et si demain
quelqu'un que vous aimez beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup
venez vous dire qu'il est différent
qu'il a une orientation sexuelle
différente
que faites vous voulez mais moins
voulons vous le rejetez comment est-ce
qu'on réagit à ce moment parce que il ya
quelque chose de plus fort que les
cloisons que les préjugés que la
discrimination que l'incrimination que
le qu'en-dira-t-on
il ya quelque chose de plus fort c'est
l'amour avec un grand a
l'amour que l'on a pour nos proches pour
nos enfants pour nos amis
pour ceux que nous connaissons ou peu
nous ne connaissons pas c'est une
fraternité pour faire avancer ensemble
une cause qui découle directement des
droits humains et parce que l'amour peut
aussi être aux couleurs de l'arc en ciel
merci